[Music]
thanks to machine learning we can
extract knowledge from medical records
call center conversations medical voice
sound bites medical forms regulatory
filings research reports insurance
claims pharmaceutical documentation and
more
this ultimately helps doctors and care
teams get holistic views of their
patients quickly or health plans to see
population trends for their members or
pharma to draw insights from drug
development research
this is possible thanks to a field known
as natural language processing which is
concerned with programming computers to
process and analyze large bodies of
human communication that can live in
many different formats such as written
texts spoken utterances or even official
documentation and so in this episode we
will share how organizations can use one
of google's natural language services to
specifically help process structured and
unstructured healthcare language data
using nlp which stands for natural
language processing
[Music]
[Applause]
the healthcare natural language api
contains four key features that help you
find assess and link knowledge in your
data in the following ways for one it
has the ability to map text to medical
concepts which is referred to as
knowledge extraction it also identifies
and connects related medical attributes
which is known as relation extraction it
can also assess surrounding factors that
could be clinically relevant known as
context assessment
and standardizes medical concepts so
they can be analyzed across systems
known as knowledge linking
another way of thinking about nlp is
that it can extract critical clinical
information like medications medical
conditions as well as understand
contexts like negation such as this
patient does not have diabetes
it also understands temporality such as
this patient will start chemotherapy
tomorrow
and even infer there are relationships
between things such as side effects or
medication dosage
and what's most notable is we have a
long list of ontologies the natural
language models are trained with two
notable ones are the icd which is used
to code and classify morbidity data from
inpatient and outpatient records
physician offices and most national
center for health statistics surveys
there's also snomed clinical terms which
provides core terminology of electronic
health records
the models also include u.s official
codes for insurance procedures and
rxnorm which contains a list of all
medications available
technical practitioners can leverage
healthcare nlp to build apps for their
own organization or for their entire
industry such as enabling precise search
and discoverability across patient
populations
enable exchange of digital healthcare
information and avoid processing delays
establish and maintain regulatory
compliance
or automate administrative workflows
such as identifying and eliminating
errors that require corrective
activities
anyone who has science-based text around
research or clinical data can get value
from our healthcare nlp api
here are a few sectors that can benefit
to name a few
in telehealth you now have off-the-shelf
support for exchanging medical knowledge
captured in written form and can extract
structured knowledge from text and make
it available for digital services such
as chat bots call centers clinical
decision support systems
this also frees up time by triaging
patient calls and resolving cases that
do not require the intervention of a
clinical professional
pharmaceutical researchers are also
enabled via a standard patient discovery
interface for population health and r d
applications since papers and clinical
trial documentation can be surfaced to
match patients or find novel treatments
those managing clinical trials can both
increase their number of participants as
well as process the high volume of
feedback and decreased time to
government approval
users who manage billing especially in
insurance companies can have even better
integration with claims payment or
automate billing and coding for
insurance
you can enable the healthcare nlp from
your google cloud projects ui or via the
command line if you do not have a
project there's a link in the
description along with other helpful
resources and once you have set up
permissions you can begin using its
context aware models to extract medical
entities relations and contextual
attributes
each text entity is extracted into a
medical dictionary entry to extract
medical text make a post request and
specify the following information in the
request
first the name of the parent service
including the project id and location
also the target text the maximum size is
10 000 unicode characters at this time
let's quickly show you how you can
leverage the natural language healthcare
api
we've built a demo application with a
javascript front end to visually
understand the output of the healthcare
nlp api
let's test out the sample medical record
for a hospital patient
we send over the sample medical tests to
the api
on the back end and we render the json
response in this web app
in the first panel down here
we can see the various entities
extracted and their corresponding
medical code
next we can see their diagnoses with
their corresponding confidence scores
now
looking at the relationships between the
entities we can actually group together
important attributes
for example
take a look at how long and how much of
these medications are taken or were
prescribed
there are so many possibilities when
using healthcare nlp and especially when
you pair it with google services such as
dialogflow ai for a chatbot interface
you can even build custom models to
build low code apps using automl entity
extraction for healthcare so that users
can simply upload documents and then
perform manual annotations to train and
build a model on what they would like to
extract
this can then be integrated into larger
data pipelines you can also use document
ai to process fax documents or enable
enterprise search for life science
organizations using the google knowledge
graph
to learn more about the healthcare
natural language api you can visit
cloud.google.com healthcare docs
concepts nlp
and community if you found this episode
helpful please subscribe to the channel
to get notifications of more healthcare
episodes
cheers
[Applause]
you